we begin with breaking news on the cost
of living crisis well in terms of how
much we're all earning and whether or
not that is keeping up with inflation
real terms wages have fallen by more
than four percent in the year to june
the biggest slump since records began in
2001. the chancellor nadeem sahibwi is
however looking on the bright side
saying the jobs market is in a strong
position with unemployment lower and
then at almost any point in the past
40 years
well let's bring in our business
correspondent helen ann smith who's at a
royal mail sorting center in east london
this morning and i suppose helen ann the
chancellor whilst technically right
doesn't exactly tell the whole story
there
yeah that's exactly right um it's worth
saying actually although uh employment
is at very very low levels for the first
time in two years the number of
vacancies in the economy actually
dropped and that's sort of a little
nerve-wracking going forward in terms of
whether those high levels of employment
sustain but look as you said the figure
that we really tend to concentrate on we
certainly have in recent months within
this data about employment and the work
the workforce more generally is about
wages and how are wages behaving in
relation to inflation essentially is the
amount of money that people are getting
paid keeping up with the cost of living
which of course is very very high at the
moment and the short answer to that is
at the moment well not really uh
inflation will real wages that's once
you account for inflation fell by 4.1
percent in the three months uh to june a
very very big fall worth saying that's
compared to a particular measure of
inflation that really takes a look at
the day-to-day cost of living something
called the cpi but you might wonder why
i'm in a royal mail sorting office well
come and have a look around this is
where a big site in london if you live
anywhere in london in the centre or the
north your mail is likely to have come
through here
the postmen and women
starting to get their sort of sacks
sorted starting to get their kind of
deliveries ready they will start heading
out very shortly uh all of this mail
will have been through electric
processes first to order it by postcode
and have a look at this this is
fascinating in terms of how it works did
you know that every single address in
the whole country has got its own little
slot uh in a slot just like this
a
house every single flat has got its own
little slot and and the workers are
sorting those letters into those slots
ready to take them out but it's
important to say that letters are
increasingly a smaller part of the
business here at royal mail replaced
largely by parcels it's a much much
bigger business parcels and there's a
whole separate parcel section downstairs
um here but that matters they say
because they say they need to adapt the
business but the workers here are saying
that their wages are not keeping up with
inflation they have balloted to strike
here at royal mail and there's a lot of
difficult ongoing negotiations about
that with rural mail saying they need to
modernize the workers saying their wages
need to keep up with inflation implement
to say they are not the only workers in
the country nurses teachers railway
workers underground workers all these
different unions uh pushing at least
discussing whether strikes are on the
table because as those figures have
shown wages really not keeping up with
the cost of living at the moment